[Musique]
il y à bien longtemps alors je
travaillais dans une parfumerie des
champs-elysées un homme entra dans la
boutique et me demanda de flacons d'un
même parfum l'un pour sa femme et
l'autre pour sa maîtresse car vous
comprenez je ne peux tout de même pas
rentrer à la maison avec le parfum d'une
autre au mois de mai suivant
une dame d'un âge certain me demanda
gentiment de parfumer une mouillette
d'un fameux parfum de 1912
dès les premières inspirations jaillir
un flot de souvenirs torride et
sensuelles d'une femme passionnée une
touche de viol est une notes de jasmin
lé souvenir de mes clients ceux des
ballets de la façon la plus impudique
qui soit je me suis ainsi convertis au
confessionnal de l'amour peut-être les
prémices de ma vocation de
sexothérapeute je m'appelle aurélie
duclos je suis sexothérapeute et je vais
vous faire sentir le sentiment amoureux
amour et parfums ont une histoire
complice tissé de points communs il
existe deux raisons physiologiques à
cela au moins la première c'est la
mémoire olfactive et la mémoire
affective sont situés dans le même
endroit du cortex primaire qu'on appelle
le système limbique c'est la zone de
stockage en fête des émotions de la
mémoire affective des humeurs et même de
certaines fonctions vitales comme la
sexualité
ainsi les messages olfactif sont chargés
d'une valeur affective mémorable à long
terme
deuxièmement le lien hormonal quand vous
sentez quelqu'un son odeur sui generis
c'est son empreinte olfactive unique
vient déclenché tout une réaction en
chaîne d'hormones qui ont une influence
chimiques sur vos comportements amoureux
et même sur votre attachement ainsi
amour et parfums ont une histoire
complice tisser de liens communs la
composition olfactive d'un parfum tel
que vous le voyez à l'écran est une
pyramide dont le parfumeur lorsqu'il
crée composent son parfum cherche à
trouver un équilibre notes de tête note
de coeur notes de fond un peu comme la
rencontre amoureuse tête
j'aperçois son visage coeur j'ai envie
d'aller plus loin
s'il me plaît bien sûr aller creuser et
puis si on s'entend bien plus si
affinités je les repérer dans la foule
anonyme des rencontres il était unique
et j'ai eu envie de le découvrir son
visage m'interpellait un échange de
sourires fugace et soudain shit notes de
tête de la fraîcheur arrive des
hespérides pamplemousse bergamote
mandarine ou orange
je me sens émoustillé quelque chose se
déclenche en moi et je pétille comme un
regain de jeunesse comme une fraîcheur
aromatique monde lavande romarin
ça vibre en moi je palpite son sourire
matière et j'ai envie de reconnaître
d'aller chercher ce qu'il a dans le
coeur
alors le coeur c'est l'exploration
on souffre l'un à l'autre comme une
fleur rose lilas jasmin premiers
frémissements printanière
et puis on échange nos complémentarités
on essaie de composer un bouquet
ensemble le je le tue s'efforce de créer
une ébauche de nous de là bien sûr la
vue et l'ouïe ne suffisent pas on se
frôle ont ces fleurs les mains se
rencontrent touche minérale de silex à
chaud son visage tout près du mien je
sens son souffle une effluve de fruits
vieil homme mettre en émoi et je
l'embrassais premier baiser fruité tué
craquante j'irais bien dessus c'est
l'abricot ou la framboise
mais oserais-je goût de reviens-y tenace
évidemment le désir est là alors bien
sûr j'ai besoin maintenant de te sentir
et la chaîne hormonal de l'addiction
s'enclenche j'arrive à l'animalité la
sensualité les notes de fond du musc
velouté
de l'ombre gris délicat des odeurs plus
sauvage et annales comme la civette des
odeurs miel et et cuir et ton odeur
sauvage déconnecte toute raison je ne
suis plus qu'une immense zone érogène et
tout à coup on fusionne dans une vague
lente jusqu'à l'explosion fulgurante
puis refus rassasié
chacun retrouve son identité
le nous laisse la place au jeu et au tus
pour se ressourcer ton odeur reste dans
ma mémoire je reçois un manque addictif
au plus profond de moi ton sillage me
hante obsédant entêtant j'ai besoin de
te retrouver
alors vous tous qui regardé ou écouté ce
tête sur l'amour que reste-t-il de vos
amours des statistiques des performances
des profils sur le web des bons coups ou
bien préférez vous retenir quelque chose
de plus subtil comme le souvenir d'une
odeur d'un parfum un souvenir olfactif
ne vieillit pas ne s'émousse pas il est
de tous les souvenirs celui qui ne prend
aucune ride qui reste intacte
alors peu importe le nombre peu importe
la fréquence chercher dans chaque
instant amoureux
la note unique qui vous permettra
d'ancrer dans votre mémoire
un parfum impérissable et qu'importe la
durée un jour
un mois un an pourvu que vous restiez
des êtres empli d'émotion et vivent
comme cette petite dame entré dans ma
boutique un mois de mai pourrait
retrouver un parfum de 1912
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]